Before this video begins, I'm doing another giveaway with Origin PC.
Check out the link in the description, and we're giving away the Origin Chronos, which I use for my TV setup.
It's amazing. I got 4k resolution support and just play games. It's smooth. It's beautiful
It's, it's nice. And, it can do this, Look:
They even attached a meme, look at this: "a variable mounting technology patented, but can you do this?"
10 out of 10 meme, of course.
Check it out link in the description. With select systems
You can get a 256 gigabyte SSD. Other great offers check out: OriginPC.com. Great people, great computers and..
moving on with the video!
Meme Review - just kidding. It's just me! I didn't get much sleep last night, and I'm just like can we
This video will be very chill; just one video, that would be very chill. Thank you very much ok alright ok
Feels kind of stupid making a video like this because who cares what PewDiePie has to say about literature
if you follow me on Twitter,
I've been posting I've been reading a lot of books lately and a lot of people were asking, "hey
Do a book review" so here I am. it was three people that asked actually it's really weird
I don't think I've ever read this much in my entire life. It just sort of happened, and I've been loving it
I had a blast this month reading these books
Consider Phlebas, Brave New World,
Fahrenheit 451,
Children of Time, the Picture of Dorian Gray, and 12 Rules of Life.
I basically wasn't - it's not a new year's resolution or anything like that
I used to read, YouTube sort of made me completely stop
And I've been really desperate to just do other things in my spare time
and I've been loving it and I plan to keep, keep on reading and
maybe
uh, this could inspire you to read as well or
uhhhh
Might just be interesting to hear what I have to say. I don't know probably not, shut up! First book is:
Consider Phlebas or plebas or
phLeBaS. You know this is an important writer because the title of his name is five times big as the title of the book
I didn't know anything about Ian M. Banks. I know he's from - he's a Scottish writer? this was written in nineteen
1987. I don't think the title or the cover has anything to do with the book
I just knew I wanted to read a sci-fi
I got this idea that I just want to immerse myself in a completely different universe and
Space seems like a great place to go. I've been really interested in AI lately, and I thought
Maybe, maybe I can discover that. I just searched up classic sci-fi
and this is what came up. It's about the main character whose name is Horza, and he's a very interesting protagonist
He's a changer as it's called and
Whenever I, uhh
Whenever I read a
Old literature that is considered a classic
But hasn't been made into any form of movie adaptation because Hollywood would literally take anything and make a movie out of it -
But they don't - I'm always thinking why? Why has this not been made into
a movie and well
I think it's the protagonist. How do you make a movie about a character that can change into other people?
It was very interesting to have a character, that's
sort of OP (overpowered) in a sense. He can
change into other people - not as seamlessly as x-men or whatever; that blue girl or whatever -
But nevertheless he can do it he has
teeth that if he bites you you'll become paralyzed and if he even just scratches you and
He will have the same effect. He doesn't really use the powers as - just as a superhero
It's more of a way to as a power struggle
This is so uninteresting. I realize sorry, but the main cha - I just find it interesting that the main characters like he has
these really great abilities and that made it really fun. It's basically about Horza
who is - I don't; I feel bad for not remembering this - but he's with the Idiran, which is this space
group of people. Man, I'm explaining this amazing. and Idiran is at war with The Culture which is this uh
space group of people. And Horza is uh, he wants
Through some strange turn of events, he wants to retrieve
this AI that had crash-landed on a
planet called Schar's World
That's the story. A lot of things happen in between but if you write a summary of the plot it can be extremely short
But it is a space opera in a sense that a lot of cool stuff happens
You know? They, they fight at a temple,
They play this crazy space game; things that it wasn't really necessary for the plot
but it was fun to be part of the journey and
That's what I enjoyed about it. Iain the writer loves the culture. It's very clear while reading this that he loves describing
What? the civil - space,
civilization is, what their morals are, what their ideas are and
He spends a lot of time on this and personally I found it a bit boring after a while
I wanted to know more about Horza. Why is he part of the Idiran?
Why does he want to retrieve the AI so badly? What is his motive as a character?
What is that drives him through to to want this so badly?
We never really find the answer to that which I find to be kind of annoying
But it wraps up nicely in the end and it's overall just a fun space adventure
I think that's really all it is so I would rate this 3 out of 5 stars
It was alright. It was okay. Moving on: I wanted to read a dystopian futuristic
Sci-fi. I read 1984 by George Orwell before and it's one of my favorite
Books it was a book that really left that impact on me
I and the meaning and the story tied together really gripped me and I think about it a lot. A lot of people
suggested Brave New World by Aldous Huxley, which is very similar to 1984 but
they sort of tackled the same issue but
Completely different perspectives. Basically, uh Aldous describes a future - this was written,
1934 I think or something like that, a long time ago - and Aldous describes a
a future horror scenario
Human as a society. I think the year was like
2150 or something like that - we have a society where we are just perfectly content
There's no problems, there's no diseases, people are born out of labs
Through the Bokanovsky effect, people are born in- without a mother or a father
They're just genetically produced. People are born into hierarchies
So you have the hierarchies and social casts of alphas being the top guys Beta Gamma Delta's is that the right order and?
Everyone is just content where they are. The alphas are happy they're not deltas, and Delta's are happy
they're not alphas, and if there's ever a problem
for the people in the society they just take soma; they, they brainwash themselves with drugs, and they just feel better
It's sort of plays on the blissfully ignorant
sort of way of living
And this is how people want to live this is how people are happy to be.
Then, another character gets introduced who grew up outside of civilization, he's called a savage
He is basically us he is
he has the same ideas and values as we do and he meets this new world, a brav- the Brave New World™️
the civilization that is completely different and the contrast between the savage and the civilization was hilarious
I laughed so much while reading it. As an example: He tells the civilization that he has a mother. *civilized Pewds* a mother? HAHAHA
I love her *civilized Pewds* you love her? HAHAjsHA
It's very funny, I'm not even sure it's supposed to be funny
But I, I laughed out loud a lot of times while reading it, but then
The story like I said it might not seem as bad as in the beginning, but the story turns very grim and
You understand that things are- this is not a way to live. This is actually a horror scenario and
The ending left - just like 1984 - a very big impact on me. I think about this book a lot after reading it
I love this book. I think it's a masterpiece
5 out of 5. It's an incredible piece of literature. I could not recommend this enough if you like a dystopian future
So you probably read it already anyway. It's very interesting as well to compare it to 1984
1984 which is written by George Orwell
Described a future just to oversimplify. He described a future
Horror scenario as well where the government doesn't want you to read books
I guess you can say, but Aldous describes the same fear, but he describes a future where society
Doesn't want to read book- we just rejected it where we reject the knowledge ourselves
So it's very interesting to have to two fears brewed into different
uh, perspectives. Moving on, I don't need to go on too much
So naturally I wanted to read more dystopian because I read two,
and I loved them, so a lot of people suggested Fahrenheit 451
written by American writer Ray Bradbury, and you see here on the back: "Ray Bradbury's gift for storytelling
reshaped our culture and expanded our world." - Barack Obama. I hated this book
comparing this book
to
Brave New World, it makes this seem so shallow
and so petty. I'll try my best to explain why I didn't like this book because I know a lot of people love this book and
I know a lot of you probably have read this book because ironically your teacher told you to read this book- I bet you
that's the case. And the irony of that is that it probably will turn people off right reading books
Because it's not an interesting story, but it carries a very important message
So, so teachers want kids to understand his message about why literature is important
But it's just gonna turn them off. That's how I imagine it. Anyway, I need to explain what this book is about, sorry
It's about Guy Montag who's a firefighter,
Sorry, he's a fireman, but he doesn't extinguish fires, get this: he, he burns books
Burning books, guys, burning books is BAD obviously
That's an important message
But I just found it to be told in a very shallow and uninteresting manner the meaning was the story
And not the story itself, which I found to be kind of annoying. I didn't care about guy the firefighter. I didn't care
what happened to him and
It just made it not really interesting
I read that apparently this book was written in a few days or maybe it was a month and you can tell
I compared his writing style to, to
Huxley it's this is a joke. I felt like sense it didn't really have a story, I'm just reading
Ray Bradbury's ideas and his fears directly, and it just came across as kind of petty and
Anti innovation, maybe at the time it was more reasonable to have the fear that in the future
We're not gonna care about books anymore. That's Ray Bradbury's fear. His fear that we're gonna listen to the radio
While doing other things and he makes a good point actually now that I think about it about, how
we want to consume media so quickly now, that I did resonate to and he
he sort of goes over the top with it
he seems like the kind of person that will tell you don't spend too much time in the front of the TV because your
eyes will become squared and to me that just seemed like
Against innovation in the future. Yes, he was probably right about how quickly we want to consume media
But people still read books just because we have computers and television and radio
That doesn't turn off from anything
Maybe I misinterpreted
But that's just how I understood the writer. Because of that I can't give this book too high of a rating
I will give it a two out of five
I don't really understand its price, and I would not recommend this book
I would much rather recommend a book like this or 1984
Next. book. So I asked Marzia what her favorite book was it's the Picture of Dorian Gray by Oscar Wilde
another, *smol kiss*
fine piece of literature, and I understand exactly why Marzia loved this book, it has a
meaningful, uh
a meaningful story with sort of horror elements to it
And I think, uh that hits, uh that's what Marzia would be interested in. The story is about Dorian Gray who gets painted by
Basil, this painter and
The third character, which name is Lord Henry. It's kind-
I don't want to get too much into each character, but basically Henry, and it gets really infatuated by this Picture of, of Dorian
It's just such a beautiful picture that he painted
That Basil painted, and, and Dorian himself really adores his pic- painting, every one loves his painting
But it's between them that that it's been painted *Doria* This is incredible and incredibly beautiful, man
He's, he's the perfect
perfect being it's described as and he's a
He's in a high social caste. He's well regarded
He's rich, and he has it all, basically he has everything you could possibly want
But he realizes that he's not gonna have this youth, this beautiful face forever, so he
he sort of wishes that he could have it forever
He wishes that he could look this young as his picture and as beautiful as a picture forever and that becomes his curse
because he doesn't age at all and,
Instead the picture becomes a reflection of his soul. Lord Henry,
I would describe as - he's older than Dorian.
he is, he's lived a fuller life than him and he has experience and I think he looks at
Dorian sort of as him- himself in the past and he gives Dorian advice through different things
And maybe I'm describing the plot too much
Sorry it-I, I think it's just interesting
Dorian uh
Makes a mistake and here's what I really resonated with this book
He had the choice to either double down and just treat it as he did- it wasn't his fault
I think as anyone can do when you make a mistake you can either own up to it
Or you can confess that yeah, this is my mistake. I made a terrible mistake. Lord Henry, I would almost say is his, you know
Devil on the shoulder and he tells Dorian
No, you didn't make a mistake at all what you did was fine and even myself while hearing Henry's
Claim, I was like yeah, actually he didn't do anything bad
- Obviously he did - But it made it resonated to myself with like mistakes I made especially on YouTube where you turn
it's hard to confess to the world that you made a mistake it may not seem like it and I
Went through that myself in my head where I'm like well, I didn't really make a mistake
It's not really my fault, and I shouldn't have to own up to this
but I'm glad I did because you don't want to end up like Dorian Gray because
Basically since the painting, It's a reflection of his soul, the painting becomes more tainted
By this path that Dorian has been led upon, and it's a very interesting story about vanity
about how one mistake can lead your whole life astray and
It's extremely well-written, and I really really really enjoyed this book
I thought it was fantastic and I totally understand why it's Marzia's favorite book
I would rate this 4 out of 5. Next up:
I wanted to read sci-fi so I read Children of Time by Adrian Tchaikovsky this has been bought by lionsgate
I think the film studio, so it's probably going to be made into a film
How are they going to make this into a film? I don't know! does anyone know?
I think this was more what I was looking for when I in the beginning when I wanted to read sci-fi
I think this is what I wanted to read, this tackles some really interesting
topics like AI,
time,
human evolution, speciesism-
How we value other species - it was very interesting. To describe the plot without any spoilers
I think the best way I can say it: It's humanity's last hope is on this ship, and then there's also
Humanity's old Empire as it's called sort of lingering in space, and then there's this planet where
Humanity wants to go to but there's there's things on the planet so there's a power play in between the planet
Humanity's last hope and the old Empire and you follow each of these perspectives
more, or less and,
It's just very interesting. It really made me look differently on,
How we value species; I look at the humanity in the future, but overall it was just a fun space adventure.
I really enjoyed it. I thought it was it was fun from the beginning to the end
I didn't really like the main character, I guess. I didn't- I wasn't as gripped by it as,
I think a lot of all the people probably would be, it has an incredibly unexpected
Character in it without spoiling it and I don't understand how they're gonna turn that into a film
Maybe I'm making it seem more interesting in that it is but if you want to go on a modern space a sci-fi space thing
This is why I'll never read or- write a book
This is it. This is very gre- very good, very great I almost said, um I've been talking a lot
How are you still here? great because I'm trying to cut it short
I don't think I'll ever read this much in a month because the last book I read which I finished last night
Which is probably why I'm so tired is
12 Rules of Life: An Antidote to Chaos by Jordan B.
Peterson. You may know about Jordan B. Peterson already. He's very popular on YouTube
For being sort of a free thinker; he's sort of a controversial figurehead as well
And I think he's gotten a lot more flak than he deserves
Because of it, because he's very cut and dry with his
ideas
Which is why he's been so embraced by the internet and disliked by media which I can sort of relate to
Have you seen that interview he did with uh channel 4? It's sort of gone viral
It's became a meme almost because the lady that tries to interview Jordan
Try and strawmen argue against him. she keeps going, "Oh, so you're saying this," *actual vid* "but you're just saying that's the way it is"
You're saying, *unknown* women have some sort of duty,
Jordan: so if you want me gone
Why you should dominate, but you're saying basically it doesn't matter. if, it made,
It made, her goal was to make him look bad and trash Jordans name in this interview
He completely shut her down, and he made her look really vicious and really spiteful
And he'd really made me want to read this book because of it cuz I was like wow that's really impressive and the Channel 4
News lady if you read the damn book you wouldn't have fallen into that trap he even discusses strawman
arguing, and why that's wrong in, in the book
- Ha gotcha - anyway, about the book itself. Twelve rules of life. I didn't read the title it's a self-help book
I don't think I ever would have read a self-help book. It gave me a lot of new perspectives that I never thought I
Would even have, it was very interesting even reading about advice that doesn't resonate with me at all
But just to understand all the people. Jordan goes very deep in
philosophical thinking and psychological thinking and he makes this very
Simple claims, right? uh tell the truth for example rule eight or at least don't lie we know that
We know not to to lie and we know the moral implications of that
but he goes so in depth in a philosophical and like I said a
Psychological way, and how that by telling lies it really,
twists your worldview. I really resonated with it that was the only rule where I was like
I don't ever want to lie this is he really makes a great point here
So I thought that was really interesting . There was a lot of rules
I didn't I didn't need to read at all about raising kids or like how to deal with- the cope with the
failing marriage and that sort of stuff.
But you can tell Jordans goal for this is to help people you can really appreciate that at least I think he
Unfortunately does it in a way that he goes on a little too long sometimes.
Sometimes I find it a bit, uh
Beating the point to death and some of the analogies that he made seemed strange at times.
They didn't really seem like they fit. He draws, uh,
He draws comparisons and analogies from Disney movies to old biblical stories
And there's a lot of religious analogies in this book a lot of religious analogies
And I didn't realize until the very last chapter. I was like he's religious
I thought he grew up in a
Christian household or something like that and and the reason that he drew a lot of religious analogies was because
To prove the point that we always knew about this or maybe this is something that we we've known for thousands of years
Through this biblical text. Whenever I look at self-help
I can't help
But feel a bit critical like is it what is this some sort of cult
book or something like that? and, and finding out that he was religious in the end and
it sort of
Changed my perspective on the book
I know that's kind of stupid maybe but he even, even Jordan himself brings it up that the past can, can
be changed from the future and
and finding out he's religious, eh
It's not that big of a deal, but I feel like it's probably unfair for me to say but anytime self-help
I'm like this is just some sort of cult following bullshit
It's not it's not at all, but it made me look more critically at the rules
Which I think you should do any time you get advice, about how to live your life.
so I think that was fine, It didn't it didn't ruin anything for me, but I
Surprisingly like I said. I really enjoyed this book. It was very fun to read, I will definitely take some lessons from this book
Absolutely and it also made me understand other people around me better. That was the book I read in January
I want to keep reading. I hope this was fun to listen to I know I've been going on a long time 30 minutes
It's probably cut down a bit. I had a lot of fun talking about these books I
Had a lot of fun this month having a hobby that doesn't involve YouTube. I used to, I used to read but
YouTube just took over my life, hopefully this might inspire you to read more as well
And maybe you'll pick up one of these. Next month, if you want to join me
ehh, Book Club!
I know already which books I'm gonna read next month; not all of them
But I know I want to read Beyond Good and Evil from Frederick Nietzsche. Everyone talks about Nietzsche all the time
I never read anything from him and Jordan mentioned him a lot, so I I knew I wanted to read this
I'm gonna read Life 3.0 By Max Tegmark which is
He describes AI and how it, how it may or may not affect us in the future. He is a Swedish genius,
I don't know if his genius, but he, the people compared to the Swedish Elon Musk and Elon Musk
Even praises the book. My parents recommended this as well, so I started already a little bit, and it's very interesting
And I want to read what you guys suggest me leave you- let me know in the comments
If there's anything that you think I might be interested in. leave a like if you enjoyed, I really hope you did (Captioner: I certainly did)
If anything this is just one video
Compared to a lot of other where I go and act like a *Dorian* so that's it goodbye
Bye now, Squad FAM
Is my *Dorian* hair up like this the whole time?